Hello大家好
歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
今天要跟大家分享的
十分鐘心理學這個
主題是什麼呢？這個主題呢
其實是很多人會
跟我聊到的部分 那就是老師
我好想要做些什麼
可是我就是沒有辦法動
我很想要改變自己
可是我發現很困難
我覺得我想要變成一個比如說
我想要成為
一個可以好好照顧自己的人
我想要開始運動
我想要練重訓
我想要 可是
我好像沒有辦法為什麼
所以今天我要跟大家分享的
這個主題呢 就是
如果你想要改變的話決定會
比想要更重要
當然啦 在很多人會發現
有時候 我開始想要開始
改變人生
想要改變自己
想要讓我的生活變得更好
我會想要比如說
我想要離開這段關係
我想要開始運動 我想要換工作
可是過沒多久我的生活
卻還是一樣
我們就會發現
想改變的人
很多 但真的改變的卻很少
先跟大家討論喔！
想要改變這件事情
而沒有改變 不代表
這樣子是不好的
我們今天要討論的
其實是你想要改變
可是你卻苦於沒
辦法改變 那個沒辦法
到底是為什麼
所以我們想要跟大家討論的是這
一個我們的沒辦法究竟是為什麼？
其實有的時候
我們會誤會
想要就會是我們想要改變的
動能 但實際上
想要是一種渴望 沒有錯
可是我們有時候會
忽略了一件事情
那就是我們每
一個人的行動習慣
也就是我有時候會
討論的生存策略
或是我們熟悉的
應對生活的方法
跟我們習慣的生活方式
因此
如果我們很想要這個東西
但是呢 我的生活發現要改變成
符合能夠得到想要的東西的
那個狀態
其實很麻煩、
很辛苦、很困難的時候
我們就很難
持續想要這個東西 讓
我維持改變的這個狀態
比如說我今天很想要可以
就是去跑馬拉松
於是呢 我希望我以後每天
早上都要出門跑
個4000公尺 這件事情
我從來沒有跑步過的人
我要做到這件事情是不是很困難？
沒有錯 所以
我很想要可以成為能夠跑
馬拉松的人
可是我卻要做到
就是到這個4000
公尺 非常非常困難
這個部分就是所謂的
想要跟你的生活習慣有一個落差的
一個非常重要的關鍵
因此為什麼
我們想要卻不容易
做到 這是一個很大的理由
還有有些人會認為想要這件事情
是一個意志力
也就是說我 只要有意志力
我就可以做到我想要的事情
所以 如果今天呢？
我沒有辦法做到我想要的事情
是因為我的意志力不夠
可是有一個困難的地方是
我們今天想要做到想要的事情
如果今天要付出的代價
非常非常大
而且要維持的這個習慣
跟你原本的生活習慣真的會
差太多　的話
那個東西
並不是靠你的
意志力就可以做到的
所以有很多人會誤以為
今天我想要沒有
做到 所以就會
有些人就是用 沒有
不景氣 只有
不爭氣之類的 相信
意志力可以克服一切 但是這
可能讓我們對於自己的行動的
一個基準　有一點誤會喔！
實際上想要它 沒有辦法
讓我們完全地
可以做到改變這件事情
但是有一件事情
可以 那就是決定
決定是一種行為的承諾
它不只是情緒
也包含了你行動結構的建立
也就是說我
今天擁有這個行動意圖 並且
我會開始調整我的行為
這一整串的東西就是我的決定
譬如說我自己曾經在其他的
批評者分享過
一個例子 那
就是我以前是
一個完全不跑步的人 可是我希望
我可以維持一天 可以跑三公裡的
這個習慣
這個習慣非常困難 對吧？
可是我的確為了
自己做了一個決定 因為
我要正式去演出
我需要維持我身體的一個肺活量
所以我告訴自己
這件事情必須要做
但是是要馬上做的
到跑353公裡很困難吧
所以那個時候我就告訴自己
好 我每天
一定要做到三
公裡 但是怎麼做到沒關係？
我先慢慢來
所以我一開始先從走三公裡開始
到跑半圈 然後走
半圈 再跑半圈 走完全到
我好像覺得
可以了 再變成跑一圈
再變成跑兩圈
最後 現在可以跑
到全中間不用休息
這中間的過程
我花了大概將近1年的時間才
做到這件事
可是讓我做到這件事情 不是因為
我想要就是跑三公裡 而是我覺得
我要能夠跑三公裡來
維持我的肺活量
於是我的大腦就開始思考
那如果我決定這件事情
我要怎麼樣 可以做到這件事
於是我允許 我
自己可以用這樣的方式
慢慢一個步驟一個步驟的去做到
我們想要做到這個事情
所以當你去思考一個很大的
目標 例如說我想要減肥
這件事情就會比較困難
可是如果你今天的決定
是我希望我的梯子
可以從哪裡
到哪裡 我希望我的梯子方塊哪裡
到哪裡然後
我希望維持這樣的生活習慣 讓
我的生活變得比較健康
於是 我就會開始決定跟安排
我要怎麼做可以讓
我的生活比較健康
一點一點的改變我的生活習慣
這個時候我們大腦的執行
功能才會真正被啟動
但是有些人會說
為什麼 我們會常常
停在想要一個
東西 但是要去做決定
然後去執行
這件事情 這麼的困難
我覺得這也跟幾個狀況有關係
第一個部分是關於
我們有一個防衛基準 叫做幻想
作用 那就是當
我們現實遇到
一些挫折、困難、遺憾的時候
我們可以藉由
一些想象來獲得心理上的滿足
比如說我幻想
我可以做到這件事
或想像我已經做到這件事
光想像我改變 就可以讓大腦釋放
多巴胺 讓我們誤以為
自己開始改變
大家聽到的時候
我們就會幻想這件事情
我用的最簡單的
例子好了 各位
有沒有過 買過什麼減肥茶、
減肥的什麼藥品或減肥的保健品
因為那個就是電視上或是網路上的
一些 不管是廣告的人也好 網紅
也好 他說他吃了這個東西
就變成這樣 然後呢
你就去買 買了
你就放在家裡
或者是你就看到那個可以在家裡
運動的東西
只要你買這個東西回去做
你也會變翹
腿 然後就買回去然後那個東西
你就再也沒用過了
有沒有這樣的經驗呢？沒錯
因為當我們購買這個東西
我們會想像我們已經開始改變
我們想像買這個東西、吃
這個東西 這個
是比較容易的事情
當我做到這件事情 我就擁有了
改變的可能
而這個
幻想作用有的時候反而可能會讓
我們沒有辦法改變
另外一個很重要過程 那
就是之前我在講到內耗
跟拖延的這個部分
也就是說有很多人會覺得
我好像還在想要不要改變
可是一方面又覺得這樣子的拖延
自己 這樣好像很懶惰
可是剛剛我有跟大家說
到一件事情 那
就是當我們調整想要改變
這件事情
其實是要冒風險的 那
就是我會擔心
如果我決定了 卻做不到怎麼辦
如果我決定改變了 可是我居然
做不到 最好會不會被人家笑？
會不會被人家會覺得哎喲？
你怎麼那麼糟？會不會？
我會失望
所以 當我的大腦為了避免失敗
避免被評價
他會讓你呆在你很舒服的舒適區
可以讓你想要 可是不用做改變
因為當你做改變
或是你做一些新的行為
你就有被評價的可能
這是一個我們大腦自我保護的
一個機制
因此 這件事情不是說你
不努力或是你不認真就能決定的
我們常常會說
研究生就是每次寫論文
要想很多 但是都不寫
為什麼會這樣 因為我擔心
我寫的不夠
好 因為我擔心
我寫了會讓人失望 我擔心
我這麼努力寫不到我想要的
所以這一種行動阻礙讓
我們透過想來
逃避做 其實
它也是讓我們有掌控感的
一個方式 也就是
我如果不要做出來
我就不會被評價的這一種安全感
因此我覺得最終最
困難的事情還是會回到
我們有沒有
要把這件事情作為我想要的決定
也就是說不是只有
我覺得這樣很好
我想要變成這樣
而是對於我來說這件事情
是不是很重要？
然後我想要做這個決定
因此從想要到決定這件事情
是不太容易的 它會有
很多阻礙的方式
如果我今天要從想要變決定
我們要怎麼做呢？
在這裡有三個方式
我鼓勵大家可以去思考
首先是具體化
你的想要一就是你的
願望是什麼 這個部分我會很希望
大家去思考的 不是一個很大的
比如說 我想要減肥 這個
就是一個很大的
目標 本身這個執行
就會變得其實不太容易
可是如果今天
我想要調整我的生活習慣
變得比較健康
我希望可以調整我的飲食
我希望可以增加運動
我希望可以怎麼樣
當這一個改變變成這麼具體的
時候 我的大腦
就會開始思考 那
我要做到這件事 它要怎麼執行？
因此 所有的事情
只要變得清楚 被執行的
可能性就會變高
第二個要知道代價是什麼
也就是說做決定最困難的地方
其實不是在於你想要什麼
而是如果你做了這個決定
你會失去什麼
這一件事情
其實是對
我們來說很難持續
的決定最大原因
比如說剛剛
我說那個跑步的狀況
我跟自己說
我每天都要走三公裡
聽起來很簡單 但其實很困難
因為當你很忙的時候 當
你那天一整天個案的時候 當
你的店跑來跑去有
很多工作的時候
當外面下雨的時候
你都會想要放棄的檢視
而當你放棄這件事情的時候
如果你原本就是有給自己
一點彈性 例如說我可以接受
我每個禮拜有幾天
做這件事 又幾天沒有
做 那又還好
可是如果你是一個對
自己很嚴格的人
你每天都要求很嚴格
結果你因為某些原因
你開始放棄了要去執行這件事情
你就會很容易
覺得哦 反正
我就是做不到這件事情就放棄了
所以我覺得對
大家來說在做決定
這件事情最困難的反而是你要知道
你要做這個決定可能要付出的
代價是什麼
你對自己的理解是什麼？
然後呢？
你可以冒的風險
跟你可以付出的代價是什麼？
你能放棄的是什麼？
這些東西大家很清楚
這對我來說
當我今天決定即使很累的時候
我還是決定
要去跑步 而
我在做這件事情後 我就知道
我想要讓自己每個禮拜有
維持幾天運動 這件事情
是我的決定
而這件事情對我非常重要
我會在執行這件事情的時候更理解
我認為這件事情對
我有多重要的感受
而當你有感受到這件事情對
我真的很重要 而
我真的願意放棄
一些事情去執行的時候
你會對自己上升一種掌控感
跟自我尊敬的感覺
而這件事情會幫助你
繼續重複的 願意持續的決定
成為你可以改變生活的一個可能的
一個動能
再來最後一個很鼓勵
大家可以設定屬於你的行動儀式
這個事情是蠻鼓勵
大家在每天出門的時候
或是寫行事曆
有些人很喜歡寫小本本
就是我這個禮拜的計劃是什麼？
我今年的計劃是什麼？
有些人就會說 每1年都會
就是做一個我1年的
計劃要做些什麼的部分
其實這件事情很不錯 但
我更鼓勵的是
請大家可以每天做一下這個計劃
那就是當我
今天有一個給自己的小決定
例如我今天決定要讓自己
可以多一點點 就是運動
多一點點活動 那我
今天就可以決定
我可能不要搭電梯
我要走樓梯到公司
我可以不要坐這麼久的車
我可以提前幾站下車然後走路
到公司等等
這些東西在我每一天
就是一開始的時候
我給自己一個行為的目的 那
就是提醒我
今天想要過怎麼樣的生活
我今天決定要做到
怎麼樣的事情 會幫助
我藉由這些小小的行動
改變我的生活
然後當你開始
累積這些小行動的時候
你會發現
你想改變的東西 慢慢的就做到了
你想要改變的樣子
然後最後提醒一下大家 有的時候
大家會覺得說
要去做改變這件事情真的
很困難 要去做決定、
做行動這件事情非常困難
所以我們會想到很多原因
為什麼我 沒有辦法改變
我們會想到很多理由
那這個時候我就會
想鼓勵大家
如果這件事情對
你真的很重要 你要思考的
是這件事情真的對
我很重要
我為什麼想要做到這件事
所以我會更鼓勵大家
在你遇到困難的時候去思考的
不是為什麼
我做不到這件事
而是花一點力氣
去想我為什麼想做到這件事情對
我這麼重要
把注意力放在
你想要做到這件事情的
理由跟原因
而不是把注意力放在為什麼
我做不到這件事情的
理由可能會幫助
我們更把我們的就是力量還有力氣
放在可以開始
往自己想要生活的方向
去走的一個非常重要的關鍵
因此 最後提醒一下大家 有的
時候我們人生遇到的是困境
不是命運 我們的選擇跟決定
是真正影響我們人生的契機
當然有些人認為
不是每件事情都是這樣的
我也同意
不過 當我們相信
我們人生遇到的
是困境或是命運 可能會給
我們多一點點力氣
為我們自己做一些屬於我們自己本
想要的人生的選擇
好的今天周慕姿
放心說就到這裡 希望
今天的分享對大家有幫助
那我們下次進來掰掰一